hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast you want me to culture what
challenging requests for culture in the
clinical microbiology lab I'm Christina
jewel of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminars presented and
sponsored by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning before we start there are a few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions and leave us a
comment answers are welcome to you can
do this by hitting the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and will follow us too we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of this live window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button on the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues as quickly as
possible this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credit after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located at the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of obtaining your credit now let's get
right today's presenter we are proud to
welcome dr. Amy Lieber dr. Lieber
received her PhD from The Ohio State
University and been a postdoctoral
fellowship in clinical and public health
microbiology at UCLA Medical Center she
is a diploma of the American Board of
microbiology and active in the American
Society for Microbiology ascp and anp
she is currently the director of
clinical microglia microbiology and
immunology and Nationwide Children's
Hospital in Columbus Ohio and Jimena so
he a professor of pathology and
pediatrics at The Ohio State University
she is editor in chief of the clinical
microbiology procedures handbook her
research interests include new molecular
diagnostics and diagnosis of infectious
diseases in pediatric populations I will
now turn the presentation over to dr.
Amy Libre dr. Lieber thank you Christina
and I'd like to welcome all of you to
this conference today and thank lab
roots for this opportunity so we will
begin with my first slide so as the
title implies we're going to talk today
about the unusual request received in
microbiology and I'm going to assume a
good majority of your clinical
microbiologists or laboratory ins so you
really relate to kind of those dilemmas
that come up about what you should do
with an unusual request and for those of
you that aren't clinical laboratory ins
you'll have a peek into the world of a
clinical micro so here's the outline
will discuss a little background then
we'll discuss the culture of objects
related to acute and chronic injuries
we'll discuss a little about the
environment of the hospital and pharmacy
and what cultures might occur there and
medical legal cases and we'll do this on
a case based methodology and there'll be
two times when I'm going to ask you a
question and I hope you'll answer and
then finally a little bit about policies
in the clinical micro lab so here here's
a little guy out on the limb and it says
sticks and stones may break my bones but
you ain't going to get me to culture it
and that really kind of lies in the fact
that for several reasons sticks are
often the objects of injury particularly
with children so it relates in that way
and the little guys out on the limb and
so that relates to kind of how your
technologist might feel
get a request for this something they've
never heard of or done before they kind
of feel like they're going out on the
limb and then in micro there's lovers
and splitters well in this situation
there are people that will absolutely
not do cultures and some that might so
today I'm going to kind of convince you
what I think is right that may not be
absolutely correct but some situation
where you should culture and then
somewhere you shouldn't so what are we
actually talking about when we're
culturing objects these are requests to
test samples other than of human origin
so what we do in clinical micro everyday
is test different tissues and body
fluids to detect organisms or a
diagnosis infection but here we're
talking about something that's not
actually from a human there Perry or
pseudo clinical so they may or may not
be directly related to an individual
patient and so for that reason they
really fall outside the generally
accepted practice of what we call
clinical microbiology so here's some
examples so let's we'll talk about
foreign bodies either through an acute
injury or retained sometimes you'll get
asked to culture of fluid or foods for
example we used to culture the food for
the bone marrow transplant patients this
is a long time ago we don't do that
anymore or you might get a request to
culture a fluid that's associated with a
Bennett or a ventilator and I'm not
really sure what it is many of you might
do environmental cultures in a hospital
setting particularly to look at for
example Legionella in the water supply
or possibly terminal cleaning and rooms
where they want to assure they would
remove all the c difficile spores from
the room or that one thing you might
never have thought of so as you're
sitting here today if you have some
examples type them in and share them so
here is what i am not i'm not in
environmental microbiologist water
industrial microbiologists nor am i a
third or veterinary microbiologists or a
member of CSI and the reason I say that
is in a hospital setting the
position often thinks microbiology is
just a single discipline so why would I
know how to culture that you know water
from a dental tab but really we all know
that these are each separate disciplines
so that's sometimes the discomfort we
have in that we're asked to go outside
of our field of practice so I always
like to remind them that I am a clinical
microbiologist and that really is
associated with infections but
occasionally we go outside of that realm
so in terms of evidence you've all heard
of evidence-based medicine now where we
have to have data to support what we're
doing well in this instance there really
is not a lot of literature or actual
guidelines about what to do when we
culture objects so really it's based on
case reports or personal experience so
but i like to call tribal knowledge so I
trained at UCLA so therefore whatever
the people did at UCLA is probably what
I'm going to end up doing with these
unusual requests and as you see at the
bottom there it says the plural of
antidote is not data and so by that I'm
just saying that i'm going to give you
examples but there is no absolute truth
so you may really argue with me or
disagree but these are kind of my
philosophies so let's start with a case
so this is the case of an acute injury
and by that I mean there's an insult to
the body through some kind of object or
device and it's removed rather
immediately so here we have an image of
a brain this is a four-year-old child
and you probably can tell that there is
a pencil sticking out of his eye so he
fell while he was carrying a pencil and
the pencil wet through his orbit the
area right around his eye it penetrated
his sinuses and went into his frontal
lobes he was transported to her hospital
within the number of hours but they
obviously he ms didn't want to remove
that pencil because it's simpy ding on
you know
critical structures so to say so he went
to surgery and they removed the pencil
and they sent it to the lab so here's my
poll question would you culture this
object so yes no or it depends so you
should see a little box on your screen
that you can answer this and we will get
the answer in just a moment so with all
of these decisions and one of the
founding tenets of medicine is first do
no harm meaning if sometimes better to
do nothing because doing something may
lead to more harm than good so in all
these situations it's good to take a
step back and say what is the clinical
meaning of the result for example if we
do culture the pencil what will be the
impact on patient care and we always
like to ask the clinician if I give you
a result what will you do with it and
you think that's a simple question but
often it's kind of a knee-jerk reaction
and they're just ordering it I'm who is
requesting the culture at our hospital
we have a very close relationship with
ID position so if they ask me to do
something unusual I'll usually do it
because I think they kind of are on the
right track and we often are thinking
alike next if you don't do it who will
so sometimes if they're desperate to get
something cultured they might send it
out and then you have to worry about the
reliability of this reference lab or it
may take a long time to get results and
it will not therefore be useful for
patient care and is with all of these
issues we want to be cognizant of the
liability that may be incurred if we do
this culture and it's used to treat the
patients so this is a quote i like to
use remember ordering a diagnostic test
is like picking your nose in public you
must first consider what you will do if
you find something and that goes back
and relate
the question I said if you ask the
position what are you going to do with
this result and if they really don't
have a good answer then probably it's
not a good idea to do the culture
because again it's not a human sample
and so it's very hard sometimes to
interpret what those results might mean
so you might use this the next time you
get an unusual request and we have to
think about regulations so for clinical
laboratories in the United States
they're overseen by CMS the Centers for
Medicaid and Medicare services and the
laws that CMS uses are Clea the clinical
laboratory Improvement Amendments which
really regulate testing on human samples
so in our situation a pencil isn't a
human sample so it's a non clinical
sample and also of note it doesn't apply
to anyone that's deceased so autopsy
samples for example don't fall under
these regulations similarly there may be
other guidances for example if you're
going to do pharmacy testing in your
hospital those are governed by different
guidances or rules the FDA for example
overseas drug sterility and things so
that's an area they might oversee also
for example donor testing for
transplants is overseen by FDA
regulation and also there's public
health laws concerning infectious
diseases you might get into situations
where law enforcement is involved for
example abuse cases I'm in our Hospital
if there's a culture result related to
that then it would be involved in law
enforcement and possibly other things I
haven't even thought about so again we
have to be cognizant that if we're
culturing objects it's kind of in a gray
area of what regulations apply to that
and this is a view of a surgeon so if i
have a surgeon removing a pencil from my
child's eye if he says send it to the
lab he's not going to take the time to
think what are the proper cultures to
order or should i order that so really
at our institution we'd rather get sent
to the lab
then we have the ability to decide if
it's appropriate or not and I have to be
ware of mixed messages because often we
get mad at surgeons for example they'll
remove a ten pound piece of tissue and
what do we get we get the slob they
stuck in the tissue so we don't want to
kind of poo-poo them sending us stuff
and really ultimately it would be great
to have a discussion prior to them
sending it in a policy that's vetted by
all parties involved so the worst thing
that happens and we'll have an example
in a moment is it's the weekend and some
unusual request comes and the poor
technologist has no idea what to do with
those requests so here is the pathology
report so they went to path and they did
a gross of the pencil and here you see a
beautiful description of a number two
pencil with yellow would lead but of
note is the pointed end of the was
bloody but the lead is broken off at the
level of the wood so it was important
for them to send a path out the pencil
to pathology in that we noted that there
may be something retained in the brain
because the end of the wood wasn't there
the other thing that's not noted in this
report is in this case the parents were
actually concerned that a dog had chewed
on the pencil so now we have dog
bacteria possibly in in the in that
wound also of note also they said there
was no soft tissue noted on it so all in
all I think it was well worth them
sending the pencil to pathology and
here's some notes from a clinician this
is an ID physician who followed up on
this case so in bullet one he's talking
about what empiric therapy they started
this child on and it's a broad range
covering a number of bacterial organisms
they also culture for mrs a because
remember the pencil went through the
sinuses so if the person is colonized
with mrs a we want to be
for covering that and here in blue you
see he also asked them to send it to
micro for aerobic culture and he notes
this will only be useful in management
if an organism grows at resistant to the
antibiotic regimen he picked to begin
with so we actually did cultured the
pencil now some of you are saying that
was silly you shouldn't have done it or
somebody say yeah I would do it but how
do you culture a pencil well actually we
know it wasn't sterile to begin with
because the EMS probably the parents the
surgeons there was a lot of handling at
least on the exposed part of the pencil
when we put it in a sterile bag and
added a culture broth and then we plated
the broth and incubated the remainder of
that fluid and again he only ordered
routine bacterial culture so if you know
here's a screenshot from our computer
system it's important to try to label
this in a way to know later that it's
not actually a human specimen so here we
have a sample sent from surgery possible
contamination sample is a pencil renewed
at surgery and it grew quite a number of
organisms it grew to interrac
gram-negative rods eco a key and
klebsiella oxy toca and also grew
enterococcus and bacillus species not in
thrasis so if we think about his
coverage we had done susceptibilities
and indeed this child was covered
empirically with the drugs he chose and
if you work at a children's hospital or
even if probably in an adult hospital we
see a lot of injuries related to objects
so things like pencils or scissors
lollipops don't let your children run
with lollipops or popsicles um anything
you can imagine almost we have seen come
through the ED now they don't always
send them for culture but if you look at
the literature related to this there is
some literature a basically case report
so here's an example or a rather
shocking image this is a young lady who
was at a wedding reception and she was
dancing and she was bumped from behind
and fell on a chopstick so it was she
was impaled on this chopstick and here
you could see it broke off at the back
of her skull actually this patient ended
up doing rather well they removed the
chopstick they didn't send it for
culture but you can understand that this
went straight through her mouth so what
are the bacteria we would be worried
about it's your normal oral flora so
acute injuries in general are not that
dramatic they're usually something like
you step on a thorn and it's impaled in
your foot so generally it's really not
useful to culture the insulting object
because when you remove it minutes or an
hour or so after you get the injury it's
really not an infection at that time so
really that result of culturing doesn't
necessarily predict what's going to
actually take seed and cause infection
so the general rule is we cover these
prophylactically again based on the type
of injury and the flora associated with
it now in this case we considered
culturing it because it was involving a
critical structure the brain so if it is
involved in a critical structure or
you'll have limited ability to actually
obtain any additional cultures they're
not going to go stick a swab deep into
that child's brain necessarily so we
decided that because we knew the
clinician and he had given us somewhat
of a thoughtful response that we would
go ahead and culture that pencil so what
are the results of our poll if you can
push the survey to see how many of you
answered this and I don't see the
results ah
it's almost evenly split yes no and it
depends and really those are all right
answers so now let's move on and talk
about chronic injuries here is where you
have an insulting object but maybe it's
stuck so here's a little eight-year-old
girl who was wearing flip-flops and she
stepped on a thorn and her mom took her
right in and remove the thorn and washed
the wound and it really wasn't getting
any better so they took her to the
pediatrician and she had a course of
augmentin and antibiotic and really
still continue to have problems and you
can kind of appreciate the swelling at
the base of this toe here and so they
finally decided to go to her
pediatrician again to get some imaging
so they did a x-ray of the foot and
really saw no broken bones only swelling
a couple days later still no resolution
so they did the more sophisticated bowed
and ski and against all swelling and
then possible bone infection or
osteomyelitis in that end of that toe so
eventually this is now about two months
later she's referred to ID clinic for
management of possible osteo and so ID
ordered one more imaging study so if you
can guess what that is well I change the
slide it's ultrasound so really they use
ultrasound and here you see it covered
in a sheath where they're using it to
image into the tissues to find the
object and remove it with an instrument
and here you can see an image of the
forceps going in to grab this one and it
was a three millimeter foreign body that
they found at the base of her toe so it
had been there for a number of months
here it is retrieved you can see it's it
looks kind of small but really that
would be extremely irritating and again
it poked into her bone and caused a bone
infection and it grew bacillus species
of cool
I glace negative staff so in these cases
we feel it is worthwhile to culture the
object because it's been inside the
tissues for a long time here's another
case and again these are pediatric cases
because I work at a pediatric
institution and children of pro duties
this is a young child I think she's
about 13 months she was running and fell
in a sewer grate and they took her to
the hospital washed out the wound didn't
see any foreign body stitched it up then
you can see she continued to have
orbital swelling and was really a
concern that there was something either
in the eye or an infection so they took
her back to surgery they drained it
washed it out still couldn't find the
foreign body and finally had to have
interventional radiology come in to find
this object and again they use
ultrasound and they found this 11
millimeter piece of wood in the eye
muscle the interesting thing about
ultrasound is wood will not show up in
an x-ray right because it's not
radiolucent and so ultrasound really is
very useful to find these retain foreign
bodies and in this case the culture of
the wood group e coli and pantoea and
the culture of the wound itself only
group e coli so you could say we had
some added benefit of culturing that
piece of wood so in general for retain
foreign bodies I would say obviously
you're going to culture and gram stain
of the wound and if you choose to
culture the foreign body which i think
is useful in it depends on what it is if
it's large enough you might want to do
roll it on a solid media or put it in a
file bra and then you might make some
considerations based on what type of
object it is like if its water related
and you're in the south you might add a
Vibrio plate or if it's would a natural
wood from the outdoors you might
consider adding the fungal culture so
all those things come into play when you
can
during how to culture these and in
general the organisms are those that
cause skin infections like staff and
baby Malik strap a variety of
gram-negative rods will talk about
Pseudomonas in a moment it's very well
associated with foot wounds where you
have a puncture wound through the bottom
of your foot and then obviously tetanus
if you think you've been exposed to the
soil so let's take a little detour this
is a very interesting area when you when
i went to make up this talk all
different kinds of anecdotal reports but
here's a little bit about shoe
microbiology so it was long known that
there's an association with pseudomonas
and injuries related to puncture wounds
through shoes but no one knew where the
pseudomonas came from so this is a study
of a hundred patients these were
patients in the waiting room of a
pediatrician where they cultured the
heel of the foot and then the inside of
the shoe underneath the heel just the
surface of the shoe and they found a lot
of normal floor of the foot but if you
go down here there was very little
pseudomonas aeruginosa only one of these
out of 100 so they concluded that really
the shoe wasn't really involved in this
meaning the Pseudomonas either came from
the foot or some other part of the
environment but then a little later some
clever person Peter Gilligan's group
actually did something very interesting
they had three groups Group one was
people with no bone infections due to
pseudomonas they got their shoes Group
one and nearly ninety one-percent of
them they found Pseudomonas in the shoes
group two is a control group of used
shoes by adolescents and that must have
been fun to culture those because if you
have teenagers you know how smelly their
tennis shoes can get but they saw some
Pseudomonas obviously not as much and
they got a whole bunch of new and unused
shoes about none and the difference
between this and the previous studies
they took the phone lining
that squishy moist foam lining out of
the shoe and cultured that and that is
indeed where the pseudomonas lives it's
almost like a little culture plate for a
bacteria so you can understand that if
you have a puncture wound going up
through that through the phone it's
going to deposit those bacteria in your
tissue and this is a slide the table I
put together of objects and associated
infections so really it has to do with
the object in the organisms so for
example we talked about thorns the
classic example is pantoea associated
with them but also also things like
sporos Rick's or Rose handlers disease
we talked about wood again it's what if
the toothpick goes through your mouth
you're going to worry about mouth flora
or if you have something penetrate the
gut it would be gut flora we talked
about Pseudomonas and other non
fermenters and non-tuberculous
mycobacteria from foot wounds pitchforks
you may not be in an area where you have
a lot of pitchfork injuries but in Ohio
we have a lot of Amish and the children
often are out in the fields working very
early and so we do have injuries related
to that where we worry about tetanus
because this population is often
unvaccinated we see fish hooks and non
fermenters and vibrio missiles now in
the lips your missiles means bullets or
BB so that can be various Associated
organisms but the interesting thing is
bullets are often at such high
philosophy that they're so hot they're
really more or less sterile when they
enter the tissue and that's why
sometimes they think it's more harm to
try to remove a bullet fragment than
leaving it in place because they don't
expect it to be an infection and then
inserted objects and a children's
hospital again you'd be surprised what
you find that a kid can stick in any
opening of their body usually they don't
result in a lot of injury it's in your
nose or your your bum that they
ticket and we can get it out rather
easily bites we see a lot of 2 and we
worry about both human flora and then
for example for dog floor we worry about
pasteurella so that's kind of a little
table of that so that's kind of the
objects related injuries and I'd be
interested to know what side you come
out on on those objects but let's move
on to the environment in the hospital so
often the clinical microbiology lab is
kind of the resource for other aspects
of monitoring the health and safety of
patients in the hospital we talked about
water testing many hospitals do
monitoring for Legionella in house or
send it out we for example monitor the
water for our dental patients in our
dialysis waters you may be asked to do
sterility testing for autoclaves or some
types of drugs or compounding drugs on
pharmacy is another example this is a
whole different area we'll talk a little
bit about pharmacy testing but you need
to do your homework before you start
that and finally air sampling that can
be done in multiple areas of the
hospital at Children's we monitor on
bone marrow transplant units with some
regularity to assure the quality of the
air for those patients so let's talk a
little bit about pharmacy the idea is
that within a pharmacy they're going to
have practices and controls to help
maintain a suitable aseptic environment
for drugs that they're compounding so
they're making up chemotherapeutics to
hang for the transplant patients or
other areas so they have various
approaches in that compounding pharmacy
environment to try to assess sterility
things like total play counts finger
touch plates surface viable organisms
and air viable organisms and this again
is a whole discipline governed by rules
or really guidelines this is similar to
clsi there is an organization
USP United States pharmacopoeia and they
have a huge book and within that book
are chapters related to how to monitor
the environment in a compounding
pharmacy so any of you that are doing
that are probably moaning and groaning
it takes a lot of effort but it's very
expensive to do this out of outside of
the hospital so there's often an
incentive to do this in-house and if we
think about it drugs are made in two
ways the manufacture of drugs the whole
plant at Eli Lilly are Pfizer is built
with the design of the primary process
there's making drugs as opposed to
compounding pharmacies here we're often
doing this within the hospital within a
small area of the hospital that's the
pharmacy so we're trying to back
engineer for these processes so it can
be sometimes difficult to maintain
sterility in these environments so this
is an example of glove fingertips
sampling so here when you're making up
these sterile compounds you have two
down and glove and we want to make sure
that those people that are doing that
aren't contaminating the product because
really it is the humans involved in the
process that are the greatest risk so
this type of training is done to assess
their ability to maintain sterility so
they gather glove and then they touch
all of their fingers to the surface of
this auger media which is then incubated
and they've stunned periodically and
interestingly there are people that are
actually totally follow procedure but
they're considered shatters in that for
some reason they really shed much more
organism than most people and really
then can't be considered for actually
doing this type of work not through any
fault of their own it's just their
biology and then here is a picture of a
surface sampling device it has auger on
both sides you lay that contact plate on
the surface
and then incubated it's designed to make
sure the cleaning processes are adequate
so that drugs can be made in these
environments and finally air sampling as
I said we do this in the pharmacy but
also in other areas of the hospital and
there's two methods to this grab it a
metric where you literally just set a
plate out and let the air settle onto
the plate or you actively sample the air
if your volume metric sampling so here
we have a picture of four different
devices used for air sampling and again
it draws through it a large volume of
air and on the bottom our plates that
are impacted by the air and collecting
spores and bacteria so here's an example
of a gravimetric plate you can see a few
colonies of mold here and some bacteria
but on the other side we can see many
more colonies of mold that shows the
increased sensitivity of this technique
from as opposed to just letting the air
passively settle onto the plate so we're
going to use always volumetric air
sampling possibly in addition to gravida
metric but certainly this volumetric is
the better method here's just an example
of a control chart that's used in the
chemo buffering area that's the area in
the pharmacy were they are actually
making up the chemo therapeutic agents
in that compounding pharmacy so they
periodically every month of monitoring
and there is an action limit that line
in red and when the colony counts go
above that limit that's when we need to
do remediation they're going to look at
the processes do some terminal cleaning
and retraining again all to prevent
contamination of these drugs used in
patients now we've talked about what is
a compounding pharmacy and this might
spark in your memory a really tragic
event that occurred
to the New England compounding center so
this was a farm a compounding pharmacy
that was making up sterile preparations
of methylprednisolone and these drugs
were injected directly into people's
spine or joints to relieve pain and what
happened is they were making up large
batches and they said them and
eventually there were over 700 actually
751 cases of fungal infections related
to these steroid injections in 20 states
with 64 deaths and here you see the map
on the right the primary fungus was XL
Highland well stratum that they isolated
here we up in the upper right hand
corner its Adam a DHS mold it's common
in the environment and here's an example
of one Pain Center in Michigan where
they faxed in order for 400 vials they
gave it to 625 patients 217 were
infected in 15 died so the sterility of
that environment and following practices
is very important and indeed on
inspection this pharmacy was not
following proper policies and procedures
number one there were making up large
batches for distribution not just
filling a prescription for a given
patient and eventually there were over
15 arrests related to this and all the
deaths and also it's very important if
you're going to do sterility testing in
the pharmacy that you get your really
understand what is involved alright so I
said we do monitoring of air cultures in
our patient units and here's a story
related to our own facility so we
monitor on bone marrow transplant units
quarterly and the results are then
monitored by infection control there is
guidance related to bone marrow
transplant units and saying that you
need to assess the quality of the air
along the other things and
we do that and our sampling in May was
actually unusual in that all 21 of our
samplings were positive for some level
of mold now I will tell you that in the
summer months these colony counts go up
a little bit but never all of them and
the other thing to remember is that the
amount of mold detected in these units
even when it is detective is orders of
magnitude lower than in your own home
there are millions of mold spores in
your own home but in this case we were
predominantly seeing penicillium species
in cladosporium so there was a great
deal of concern and we did some
investigating and part of that
investigation involved going up to the
air handling units on the top of the
building associated with the bmt unit
you can see the baffles these are the
air handling things between the HEPA
filtering and you can see some little
spots on it if we look a little closer
we can see a lot of little spots and
actually we did culture this and it grew
mold now this isn't to say this level of
mold was getting into the bmt because
there were HEPA filters between but
certainly we see the penicillium that
lighter green and the darker mold is the
cloud of spore iam here's both just we
tried to quantitate this but certainly
there is a lot of mold there so what
happened then is they removed all of
those air handling units and bleach them
replace them replace all the filters and
now we've instituted a more regular
inspection of these units but often this
probably goes unthought-of in terms of
monitoring the other thing we found out
is our hospital is located in an urban
environment and on various times and
particularly at new years there are
gunshots in the area and so what we
discovered is there was a leak around a
window that allowed moisture to impinge
into the drywall and it too was growing
penicillium it was actually related to a
bullet hole in the ceiling the
roof actually and there are many
probably most hospitals in urban
environments you could find bullet holes
in the ceiling I learned that and the
other issue is you shoot it up at a high
velocity and then on the way back down
these bullets gain velocity so they can
penetrate through you know hard surfaces
so we've instituted a more regular
bullet hole surveillance on the roof so
let's get issued with some do-good on
time some medical legal issues related
to request for culturing so here's a
scenario we have a nurse who notices a
cloudy substance in an unopened
single-use vial of heparin now heparin
is a manufactured drug it's not
compounded right so come straight from
the pharmaceutical company she doesn't
use the vial and she calls the pharmacy
pharmacy checks the other vials with the
same lot number and there are also from
other vials that look yellowish and
cloudy so they call the lab and ask if
you would analyze this material so I'll
pause a moment just to ask you would you
culture this object I'm just going to
give you the answer because this is
clearly know this really involves
regulation by the FDA this isn't
something a clinical labs you
necessarily get involved with and there
is a mechanism to report this through
med watch and here's like a screenshot
of the men watch site and it says that
product problems should be reported
things with quality authenticity
performance or safety should be reported
and really it's important to report
these in real time so that if the FDA
gets more than one warning orchids call
about a product they can issue a recall
or guidance more quickly so these are
situations where we would not get
involved in culturing it it's an
unopened vial of a manufacturer drug
but the next scenario actually happened
and it again is a medical legal case so
this happened on second shift on the
weekend and so everything in in micro
and in the lab in general happens on
Friday afternoon or on the weekend so
they got a call and requesting a stat
Gram stain on a culture of an IV fluid
so the technologist is like well okay if
you said it I'll do it so they sent it
but it didn't have any orders associated
with it so she called back up and said
there's no orders and they just said no
you don't want to order it please just
do the Gram stain so she did and she
reported out few yeast and no cell seen
she said I'm not going to do the culture
I don't know how to culture this so she
held it in the refrigerator so on Monday
morning they called me please culture
this fluid when the situation was this
this is an IV bag with that was going
into a 17 year old patient of Ames um
this is a patient with complex medical
history who had undergone a gastrectomy
and had an ostomy bag hanging along with
some other medical conditions so the
nurse one by the room and the IV was
alarming and she went in and saw this
cloudy fluid so you can kind of
appreciate there's a cloudiness to it
and also here is the filter before it
goes into the arm and again you can see
particulate matter the mom was in the
room as she was acting very nervous and
then was trying to dump the IV bag down
the drain so there was a great amount of
concern and here we're getting into a
medical legal issue because it was
concerned about how did that material
get into this IV bag so here's a
situation where they asked me to culture
this so again I'm going to ask to pull
you would you culture this fluid so
hopefully our little poem will pop up so
while you're answering that I will tell
you what we did
link we actually did culture the IV
fluid the idea being we wanted to know
what if anything bacterially was going
into this patient because it really was
affecting this individual patient even
if it was a medical legal issue so we
actually spun down 25 mils of this fluid
and plated the sediment and here's what
it grew again we try to identify it as
not necessarily a human sample it was an
IV fluid and improved many Candida
albicans and view enter caucus cesium
which was V vancomycin-resistant you
might think well hmm where did that come
from well it it turns out that the
patient had been on many many
antibiotics because obviously they were
undergoing surgery for the gut so he had
very reduced normal flora and so this
was actually a case of the mother with
drawing fluid from a syringe from the
ostomy and putting it in the IV fluid
line and this was his actual school
flora he grew up kidded albicans from
the blood also so in this case we felt
it was very useful to help treat this
patient to culture this fluid I learned
a lot during this incident I talked to
lawyers I talked to the police they did
remove this material and send it to a
forensic lab but the idea is that a
forensic lab is not designed to be a
clinical lab so the turnaround time is
much longer and in fact it took I never
even received the results of forensic
studies so in this discussion with this
actual incident again I talked to one of
our attorneys and for them the
overriding principle is again will it
benefit the patient all the way back to
the beginning that risk benefit ratio
and in this case the answer was yes so
she said go ahead and do this I'm the
forensic results
not clinical results due to turn around
time in this case it really wasn't a
chain of custody so we have that process
under review but still we want to handle
this as we would a patient sample in
that we've got we eventually gave it an
accession number in those types of
things and you really do need to
consider carefully whether this it's put
in the patient record in this case it
altered treatment it helped guide
therapy so we did put into the chart but
what I learned also is that if there's a
consideration that the pic the
Munchausen by proxy is what this is
called and in those cases sometimes if
there's the parent thinks there's a
suspicion or something it might
accelerate harm so you really do need to
be careful in these instances so just my
opinion on asta culture kind of fluids
or objects fluids and syringes not
directly associated with patient care I
would use caution and open drugs we
talked about don't do that sterility of
materials used in treatment so things
that come out of the compounding
pharmacy I'd be very cautious if you ask
in the lab to assess that and then
anything that does not have a media tour
significant positive impact on your
patient I would use caution and then
with all things in the clinical lab we
have to find a way to communicate the
results and again you might put it in
the lis but you want to make sure it's
clear it's not a human sample there may
be occasions where you do you think it's
better to do it verbally or by email but
whatever way you do it you want to keep
thorough documentation and issued proper
disclaimers and then in terms of
building it's difficult to understand
because it doesn't really fall under
CLIA but you want to consider when
Medicare and Medicaid deem this
acceptable and pay because otherwise the
patient may be stuck with the bill so
sometimes will absorb the cost of these
types of things in the laboratory
we talked about risk that risk benefit
ratio it could contribute to an adverse
outcome because we're exposing the
hospital to liability and again we could
set a precedent for bad habits I'm
guilty of this I'll give in to a request
not necessarily miss arena to a
physician and then they come back and
want it often and even if the physician
or the surgeon says I I'm asking you to
do this I'll take responsibility really
view the director more or less it still
has accountability now there are no
there's no way to write a policy for
these unusual culture requests um but we
do have a policy and really it says
consult the director is one of the first
caveats and to hold all of these items
in the refrigerator so for the most part
we're trying to maintain the level of
organism we don't want / growth to occur
so we put it in the refrigerator and if
you have some type of rudimentary policy
it's it's a starting point for
discussion and the people you really
needed that the table are people from
surgery infection control epidemiology
and other clinical groups that are
sending you these kind of unusual
requests the bottom line is you want to
give the technologist who's there on the
weekend in the middle of the night
something to go by to help them
understand what to do so let's see the
results of our poland would you have
cultured that fluid drumroll please yes
i agree because it had impact on the
patient so sixty-five percent of you
said yes and that i would agree with all
right so we'll close out with this final
question this is a Seinfeld and mrs.
Kramer and they were watching a surgery
for Elaine's boyfriend and somehow
Kramer decided to bring junior mints
into the operating theatre
and one of them gets loose and ends up
in the middle of the the sterile field
so would you culture that object that
seems like a funny question but actually
I've heard stories of requests to
culture flies that were found in the
surgical suite that landed inside the
patient so it's not that far out of the
realm of possibility so in summary we
talked about the request to culture
unusual objects should be considered in
the context of the risk-benefit ratio
for the patient I think you need to
recognize the ability of your laboratory
and what instances where it wouldn't be
appropriate either because it might lead
to bad outcomes or it's something you're
not familiar with whatsoever and those
instances where you should go ahead and
try to help and do the culturing
environmental culturing is possible but
you need to do your homework
particularly as it relates to pharmacy
and these unusual requests should be
reviewed by multiple parties and
agreement reached hopefully beforehand
so if you can have some kind of policy
that has a general outline of
considerations it's very helpful and
finally don't run with pencils so with
that I will close out my presentation
and if you can help me with the
questions or comments thank you
excellent presentation dr. Lieber thank
you for bringing that information to us
before we get started with all of your
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to retest today questions can be
sent via the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
with it so as many as we can first
question do you accept animal specimens
in your laboratory and how do you handle
them that's an interesting question
actually we do get requests to culture
animal specimens on we have some
research associated with our institution
and for example will often get diarrhea
stools on primates because primates
actually get diarrhea due to their
nerves they get upset but then they're
trying to distinguish that from
infectious agents so we will culture a
stool other requests are a little more
tricky because the normal flora and
pathogens of animals can be very
specific to that animal so you can get
too far out on that limb um the other
issue i'll bring up is for certain
primates like I think it's Nick acts
they carry your herpes virus herpes B
that is actually deadly for humans so I
would issue caution for those of you in
chemistry or hematology if you're asked
to do testing on primate blood to really
think twice about that
next question what can we on the
clinical MZ side of things do to help
our micro lab in the instance when we
have an object we'd like to have
cultured well first of all dialogue to
an to recognize that you at you're
asking them something outside of their
normal purview and to really have a
justification for why you would want
that done I think there are instances
where it really also depends on the
temperament of the people in your micro
lab I think there's some that you could
never convince but I think there is
justification it's the only thing is
there's not a lot of literature to
support it but if you have a good
explanation of why you wanted to do this
and what will be the consequence in or
changes in therapy that would be number
one and to do this ahead of time to call
ahead so to speak to try to get an
agreement so it's not just showing up on
your doorstep next question even in the
case of the principle of the pencil you
described the doctor still does not know
what or if there is an infection so is
it really worth while therein lies the
argument against it and I think that in
this case we did uncover bacteria but
all of them were actually covered with
the empiric therapy so you could argue
it really didn't add anything I just
feel that if it in such a serious
situation where there were circumstances
for example that the dog had chewed on
the pencil so possibly there was
pasteurella in the world I think in
those situations where there
a kind of a critical structure involved
I would argue that it is useful now it
may not be useful to culture a nail that
comes out of a foot because number one a
nail isn't necessarily very porous so it
may not hold a lot of organisms in in
the object and if it's removed quickly
so somewhere in between I think is the
answer but from my perspective we we
made the right choice and culturing the
pencil that is all the time we have for
today I would like to once again thank
dr. Amy lever over presentation dr.
Lieber if you have any final comments
bro just to thank all of you today and
please again don't run with pencils
thank you again dr. Amy lever for this
great presentation and thank you again
tomorrow sponsor lab groups for making
it possible to bring this presentation
to you today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through December 7
2016 you will receive an email from us
alerting you when it's available on
demand and hosted on Bob Lutz calm you
are welcome to forward this announcement
to any colleagues who weren't able to
join in today thank you for logging on
and participating in today's broadcast
see you next time